if you've been dying to know what it's
like to ride my poop at hundreds of
miles an hour
well this is what it looks like last
week Hyperloop won one of the companies
leading the charge to bring Elon Musk's
dream of flying through near vacuum
tubes at Porter Line supersonic speeds
set a new speed record at its test track
in the Nevada desert a 28 foot long pod
climbed into a 1600 foot long concrete -
thanks to some hard working vacuums the
inside of the tube felt like it was 200
thousand feet above sea level but the
scientists call near space an airlock
sealed the pod inside the nearly airless
tube and the pod used magnetic
levitation to hover over the track to
further reduce friction the great enemy
of high-speed travel and then whoosh
just a few seconds later the pod had set
a new speed record 240 miles per hour
that's faster than the 220 mile an hour
mark Elon Musk hit this summer and the
fastest publicly announced Hyperloop run
to go with this new result Hyperloop 1
also announced Richard Branson is coming
aboard as chairman it just raised 50
million dollars and it's got a new name
virgin Hyperloop one sure the day you
get to climb aboard is years away and
that's being generous but at this rate
the future just might wish by you sooner
than you expect
you